[Music]
this
is star talk neil degrasse tyson here
your personal
astrophysicist with my co-host chuck
knight chuck and baby
what's happening neil all right jack
chuck you know what today
is it's it's a rare thing we got to do
this because i think
people will want us to do it this is
this entire episode
is a shameless plug
for the very latest star talk book nice
that is just coming out and it and the
the reason why it's a maybe it's maybe
it's not shameless maybe it's full of
shame
the point is it's the title of the book
is cosmic queries the book was inspired
by this
spin-off of the star talk flagship
and so i just want to celebrate that
with all of our fan base and with you
and so i just thought i'd just put that
out there chuck i love it well first of
all uh
shameless shameful for me it makes no
difference
no more it's the same place all the same
so so
there's that and it's published by
national geographic books who published
the first
star talk book that's right uh you know
what the first star talk book was called
um let me hold on for a second the start
talk book
yeah i'm looking at it over here wait a
minute it was called star talk
the star talk book yeah this one
inspired by this
uh this spin-off branch of the star talk
universe
right and so and so it's questions 10
chapters and each chapter is a really
deep question that we barely have
time to address given the
nature of what we normally do in a
cosmic queries
so what for this episode we're going to
do we're going to focus on chapters
three four and five oh wow
those are how did the universe get to be
this way
how old is the universe oh that's so
impolite and
and what's the universe made of close
let's see so we we have to we have to
reach uptown for our
sort of cosmologist in the house john 11
jamnet welcome back
to star talk and you're published on
these topics you got your own books
right
so first there's together chuck the
black blues
[Laughter]
so so you've got that that book and a
more recent one
called the survivor black hole survivors
guide which is a very pocket-sized book
and everything you needed to know
to visit and not die in a black hole i
think is that that
did they characterize that properly so
how do we get to be this way
what does it mean to have forces and
matter
and energy and space yeah universe why
you gotta be like this why you gotta be
like why didn't it be like this universe
i thought we were cool you know i
thought we should
i have a star talk book idea for you
though what's that
a book a self-help book for like
universes on how to be better
like how to be a cooler how to be able
to be a badass universe
more actualized universe well actually
this is for the for the multiverse in us
all right yeah
the more acts
as an astrophysicist i can say we've got
stars galaxies and planets but you look
at it as a physicist
at a much more sort of refined level
and i see things that gather according
to forces so
what was what's been going on to give us
the universe we see today
well it's really interesting you
mentioned stars galaxies and planets
and oh my those and those
and those are things sugar's allowed one
really bad
joke
i'm a good audience i laugh at all
history okay that's very good all chokes
that's why you're my favorite guest
and uh happy birthday jen i didn't
properly introduce you you're a
professor of astronomy and physics up at
barnard college that's why i said
we go up the street because you're just
you know two miles north of the american
museum of natural history
and uh you've been doing this since
childhood and it's just been great to
have your enthusiasm
and plus you you you hosted a pbs
special but on black holes what was the
title of that
black hole apocalypse see see what i'm
saying
yeah it's nice you were the on-camera
host of that novel
one of my son's favorite that's so sweet
it is i
held a little black hole in my hand i
got to do all kinds of cool cgi
yeah yeah that's crazy but okay go on so
well so so
you all the stuff that you listed stars
galaxies planets
are are luminous objects meaning they
reflect or emit light
and that actually makes up much less of
the universe
as you well know um than we used to
believe it's actually less than
five percent of what's out there i mean
if you think about everything
anybody has ever seen or ever will see
makes up less than five percent of the
universe the universe is
in its volume has dark energy permeating
every part of space and yet it is it is
really should be called invisible
because it's not dark looking it's it's
literally invisible we see right through
it
and there's dark matter and those um
right so
people will think oh dark matter why
isn't that just black holes
but so there's a difference between
matter you can't see because it's not
giving you light and matter that you can
never see
because it will never give you light or
something yeah how would you distinguish
that
yeah no no it's a it's a really good
point i mean a black hole is really just
a shadow
it just casts a shadow and uh you have
to illuminate
behind it around it to notice the shadow
just like a tree doesn't make a shadow
in
the darkest night um so you need
you need some light source to cast a
shadow so that a black hole is just
absorbing that light
that's deep i hadn't thought about that
so yeah you only know
a tree shadow is there because there's
light yeah
surrounding the shadow the shadow is the
absence
of the light yeah the presence of the
tree is the absence of the light
the tree is absorbing some of the light
and
and if that's not that shadow falls in
the forest
well the thing you know and only the
shadow knows how's that you got me
are we good there okay so that's what
people don't appreciate about black
holes that stepping
into the event horizon of the black hole
is just like stepping into the shadow of
a tree there's really nothing dramatic
about it
um you're just you're just going into
that region where
you the light is being absorbed but
it's a little trickier because the light
can fall in behind you but having said
that dark
matter which is what we were originally
talking about doesn't interact with the
light at all there's no shadow cast
there's no darkness it just passes right
through so
there's a cloud of dark matter
presumably between me and my
computer maybe not very much from the
local universe
it affects gravity right so so it
interacts gravitationally so there's a
lot of it
and there's a big halo of it around our
galaxy so when we look at our galaxy we
think it's this
kind of planar spiral and it's so
beautiful and it's illuminated by all
the stars but really there's this halo
around it of dark matter and we look
right through the dark matter
and that halo affects the behavior of
the galaxy the evolution of the galaxy
and
and actually dominates the mass of the
galaxy so
it's just we're invisible to the dark
matter too you have to realize
it doesn't see us either dark matter
technically if it had
eyes would look right to us too
wow so this is a sci-fi story the dark
matter people coexisting
with regular matter people would just
walk through each other that's exactly
what i've been talking i could be in the
same body
right as a dark matter alien and we
wouldn't because
my gravitational field is so tiny um
won't interact at all because that uses
forces that dark matter doesn't respect
there's a movie about that it's so there
is there's a movie waiting to happen in
there
yeah man man okay so
all right so we got dark matter dark
just 95 percent of everything
and so so is it possible
no is it possible we're the anomaly
if 95 of everything
is the if 95 of everything
is the thing is it possible that we
are the anomaly that we're at the thing
right we're not
we're not the thing it depends on how
you look at it
the confusing thing about dark matter we
know examples of dark matter we know
neutrinos neutrinos exist
they emanate for instance from the sun
from thermonuclear reactions they don't
interact with light at all they are
technically invisible so we know
examples of dark matter
but we know that the neutrinos that we
know about can't be the dark matter in
the universe we just can tell it's not
heavy enough it doesn't have all the
right properties so there's something
like a neutrino so you're saying a
neutrino is an example
of a physical object that doesn't really
interact
with us but only weekly only very weakly
so this
could be matter if it's matter at all
that interacts even less
with less strength than a neutrino would
that's right now the
chuck's question is like really
interesting because it could just be
the fact that there's so little of us i
mean there should be none of us
because you asked why does the universe
got to be this way
and it it doesn't we don't really know
why there's a little bit
excess for instance of matter than
antimatter
and so it doesn't have to be this way
we're trying to figure out why it is
this way if if there was
equal amounts of matter and antimatter
when the universe was created there'd be
none of us
because we would just merge with our
anti-matter and annihilate
and there'd be nothing left but so some
law of physics that we take
as as canon was broken
or violated in the early universe yeah
and we still don't
matter always comes in matter
anti-matter pairs and we
won that contest right as this excess
froth
right uh and so so you just declare
that some rule got broken in the early
universe that sounds very
like you don't know what's going on well
that's
true we don't know what's going on
there you go so this is actually
interesting let's go have a beer
we're done here we do know that there
are slight matter anti-matter violations
in the laws of physics why there are
these tiny violations we don't know
um and there's an example so so so if
you made the universe with
equal the universe was created with a
lot more matter in it a lot more and a
lot more antimatter it all just went
away
and this little ashy residue was left of
this little excess of matter
right so so that that's what goes into
us so
could you have a universe where in fact
the matter and antimatter were strictly
equal all the way down and still have a
functioning universe
maybe not with stuff in it but is that
would it be its own
space its own place could you have a
universe
where it's like uh where
that has just dark matter and dark
energy in it and no regular matter
you absolutely could have a universe i
mean if you imagine the multiverse which
you made very quick reference to in the
beginning
you know like if you keep kind of making
universes like babies
they're all slightly different right
they have a certain
uh genetic code we know it's still the
underlying laws of physics
but maybe certain slight parameters can
be seeded differently
and so maybe there's a universe that has
no excess of matter over antimatter and
that really depends on whether or not
it's absolutely fundamental to the laws
of physics or it's something that got
broken like you said
you know for instance universe is left
right symmetric i don't expect it to be
different on my left and my right right
because that doesn't even really matter
i can move around
the universe should be the same but i
know that in this room it's not i know
that my microphone's on my left
and that's different that's broken it
just
physically even though the laws of
physics should be the same on my left
and right i love the looks on your faces
right now
for anyone who is just listening i just
got like
four eyes
yeah it's like what the hell
first of all you had me at baby
universes because my mind just started
going off to
all these other universes that were just
like you better take care of your kids
that's too many kids you got too many
kids there could be a whole bunch of
little baby universes out there
some of which are are you could say less
successful on the basis of what we think
is important
which is the emergence of sentient life
right and
you know you're not going to make a lot
of sentient life out of dark matter
presumably
now there could also be this thing where
the dark matter
sector has its whole reality it ha it
makes stars and galaxies we just can't
see them
and it sees them and it has this whole
other reality and we're just like in
parallel
completely invisible to each other dark
galaxies dark stars dark planets
all right so so from what i've read and
i have a cursory understanding of this i
have like an evening news
account of this at different times from
the early universe to today
matter gravity dark matter dark energy
all have different
ways or different strengths of their
capacity to manifest
okay so so who's dominating today
so today we know that the overall
energy density of the universe is
dominated by dark energy
and exactly as you said that was not
true very very far in the past
it it's like it's like a soup of
ingredients that compete at different
phases
and the dark energy the strange thing
about dark energy is as the universe
expands
because the dark energy is everywhere
it's like it feels more of it
so the expansion gets a little faster
and then it feels even more of it
embracial everywhere it doesn't it
doesn't dilute
right like if i if i took a hot gas and
i expanded it it would dilute and get
weaker
dark energy and that's what happens to
the the primordial soup of
matter in the early universe it's really
powerful so we're diluting our gravity
we're diluting our gravity and not
diluting the dark energy
yeah so that's right the expansion
is is we're getting further and further
away from other galaxies so that's
diluting their gravitational effect on
us
right but
okay so you compare the two the dark
energy systematically
wins out eventually it'll win even if in
the beginning the gal you know that's
not necessarily the galaxy but like the
stuff
dominated and then the universe was
expanding and it got more and more
dilute and weaker and weaker
and then the dark energy there it was
and it just took over
so dark energy feeds off the vacuum
of an expanding universe well this is it
might be
the energy of the vacuum of the
expanding universe
so the more vacuum you get the more
energy
from the vacuum you know weirdly that
reminds me of the weeping angels
episode of doctor who where
weeping angels they feed off of your
life energy
and you disappear out of your time and
you show up in the past
because they took your present life
energy from you so
dark energy is
is taking whatever we possibly had left
of ourselves it's a cosmic vampire
there's a vampire that's what it's doing
well if it keeps going like this
you know a friend of mine um used to say
we have to do astronomy now
because eventually eventually in the
very far
future there will be no galaxies in view
anymore they'll all be too far away from
there'll be no cosmology there'll be no
cosmology we know cosmology we'll just
see our galaxy and the rest of the sky
will be empty imagine
astronomy under those circumstances we'd
never know that there was anything
outside of our ground well that's what
it was
until 1920. until 1920 no one had any
idea that the fuzzy objects were
galaxies
it was just the solar system and the
stars in the night sky
and that was the universe in fact that
was the universe to einstein
there was no understanding of a big bang
or anything else
and so that's right it was just no in
fact
when did who's the guy who first
advanced the big bang the the monk
or the the priest
the belgian priest right who really put
the math behind einstein's equations
did he by then have hubble's expanding
universe
he must have i think um so friedman
uh uh and la mesha and some of these uh
you know
robertson walker there were a bunch of
cosmologists that were thinking about
this
long before actually hubble and einstein
thought they were wrong
so einstein publishes his theory but he
doesn't he doesn't know that there's a
big bang it's not like it just hits you
in the face you gotta you gotta study
the mechanics of the theory and so
people jumped in even before he did and
they realized oh this is really strange
if you imagine a universe dominated
by matter they didn't even know about
dark matter but just stuff
it actually wants to expand it's
actually heart that universe doesn't
want to just
stay static it's actually really really
hard to make it static
so i guess what i'm thinking is they're
imagining an expanding universe before
they even know anything about galaxies
they're just thinking about stars in the
night sky they were just imagining
yeah they were just imagining like a hot
stuff everywhere
you know just pretend right
so without galaxies we have no knowledge
of an origin of the universe
and we'd be dumb stupid yeah so yeah we
have to do astronomy now
because one day we're going back to that
same state yes but only because
it those galaxies won't be observable at
all right at all
but so it'd be somebody would be like
son believe it or not there was a time
where people looked up a time
and they thought that they saw things
son oh grandpa chuck
tell me more when you were a child
believe it or not son
they used to look up there and see
things but no longer
basically most the evidence that we had
a big bang in our past we'll eventually
um just fade away so so janet before we
take a break and then get to our
actual cosmic queries with people's
questions
uh what i lose sleep at night wondering
whether we today live in a time
where an entire chapter of data
has been removed from our awareness just
as
it will be in the day when there are no
galaxies
in a post-apocalyptic civilization they
will know nothing of chuck's stories
about the day gone by and they will try
to figure out the universe
with what they've got so what what
chapters are we
missing today thinking we have
full access to all the data yet we don't
and that's funny because i lose sleep
because i normally drink vodka before
bedtime
okay we should yeah we should have
little shots for our
like if you get if you get the cosmic
query wrong
[Laughter]
so you know so jenna you don't worry
about whether we're missing something
i totally do but i think this is a
really interesting question because
people say things like
if there's no way to observe the
multiverse then it's not a scientific
question i think that's false
for instance in the far future if people
say there's no way to observe other
galaxies and i don't know why and one
person
pontificates maybe it's because the
universe was expanding so rapidly that
they're now beyond our view
they'd be right but it's technically
untestable for them right
so i i do think it's a scientific
question even if you can't resolve it
observationally so yeah there are things
like if the universe has extra spatial
dimensions
and and right now they're really small
and we're really big maybe that's
something we can't test right now but
maybe in the far far past it was
technically testable
wait so chuck she's saying one day a new
dimension is going to grow out the side
of your body
since the pandemic that has already
happened
mercifully we're all like filmed from
here
[Laughter]
chuck out six legs
we gotta take a quick break when we come
back janna you're here for us
uh we're gonna take questions from our
patreon members on these very deep
segments when star talk returns
we're back star trek cosm aquarius
this is a celebration of the release of
the second star talk book
called cosmic queries inspired by this
spin-off
of our show one of one of our more
popular formats
of the star talk portfolio and chuck i
got you here for this of course
that's right and we're doing uh chapters
three four and five
and i got their titles right now how did
the universe get to be this way how old
is the universe
and what's the universe made of and
chuck you've been collecting questions
let me just lead off
janet i've heard people say the universe
is designed just for us
okay just so that we can have life but
that seems really inefficient
if life as we care about it human life
has been around only for a couple
hundred thousand years and the universe
has been around for 14 billion
that just seems really inefficient so
so if you want to say you know
everything's set up for us
that's a pretty big waste of time and
space
yeah especially if we're just here to
make plastics for a little while and
then we're going to go on
and leave the plastic behind you know
the plastic will survive us
it's like a george carlin skit he's like
the planet just wanted us to make
plastic for it and then be gone
right because there's no known thing
that dissolves plastic
right yeah not yet so chuck give me some
questions
dude all right here we go let's uh ball
from patreon
give it to me everybody's from patreon
and this is
richie uh damani
richie damani says firstly janna neil
chuck thanks for taking the question
so we know about the lhc at cern
uh which has made huge discoveries in
particle physics
but do you have any knowledge
of a larger project that it is in
consideration
that will further our knowledge of the
quantum
world yeah janna is there another
particle that people think is out there
and now we need something bigger than
the large hazard on the collider to find
it
well dark matter so so the large
hydrogen collider has
been very successful it's very exciting
it discovered the higgs particle which
explains
why anything has mass what did you say
hicks particle or higgs boson pigs
i thought you said the hickory part was
a little different
the his particle explains why you eat
possums very culturally insensitive yes
exactly
just the hits particle is just like i
believe i'm uh
on a quantum level y'all
constantly barbecue that possibly all
right
well so you know it it's called the god
particle
in like sort of colloquially but it's
it was originally called the goddamn
particle by leon letterman
um the nobel prize winner he wanted to
write a call his book the goddamn
particle because i hadn't found it yet
and his publisher made him change it to
the god particle which he said ended up
alienating two groups those that
believed in god and those that didn't
so it's since stuck it's stuck yeah
um so but the lhc could have detected
dark matter and that would have been
really like that would have just
been what everybody had mostly hoped for
and it hasn't so
could we go higher energy and higher
energy if you think of the energy
of the large hadron collider it's from a
very early
era in the universe's history and you'd
expect to be able to make
kind of everything the earlier back you
go the more you can make
more kinds of vocals i never thought of
it that way you're telling me the lhc
is a kitchen it's a cosmic kitchen and
so
if you whatever energy you hit you just
look on your cosmic scale and say i got
you back to
three seconds in the big bang and then
higher energy got you back to one and a
half seconds
so where what how much how much more
energy you're going to need
to get to the formation of dark matter
in the early universe
like 10 million times higher
oh okay chuck that's all right
yeah we got that you got this not a
problem right and so that's really 1.22
gigawatts of energy
that's what we need like 1.21
gigawatts and we're going back in time
too so yeah
so in the recipe book that neil's
looking at that tells you if i cook at
this temperature i'm going to have this
number of particles
that's just based on as much as we
understand and as much as we understand
between
the energy of the large hydrogen
collider and the very very
you know the earlier second of the big
micro tiniest little fraction of the
second the big bang
is like 10 million higher
in energy but it doesn't mean we're
right i said there could be like a bunch
of stuff that starts to appear
that we had no idea about that and
that's what everybody's other stuff like
not just like dark matter might appear
in
there
you know and other stuff might maybe
dark matter isn't alone maybe there's
like a
whole dark sector a whole dark reality
and we start to discover tons of dark
matter particles and
forces dark forces so jenna i love this
you're saying
a more powerful collider could just open
up a whole new door
to what's going on in the in the
universe cooking with particles
now we do know that we can't we will
never hit certain scales with
the usual technology like you would have
to have all the resources in the solar
system and a
particle collider the size of the solar
system so that's why we do
need 1.21 gigawatts of power
established just just think of just
i don't not to beat that to death but
just think of doc
brown hearing marty tell him in 1955
oh yeah it runs on 1.21 gigawatts of
power
and doc brown freaks out and he says
you're from the future i'm sure
plutonium is just available
at your local drug corner store but in
1955
we can't have one point twenty one so do
we have to wait
the the forty years or whatever so are
we on our
arc to get there i think that's the
benefit of astronomy is that stuff
happens at higher energy scales than
human beings can
engineer and so we we know we have high
energy particles hitting our atmosphere
from supernova explosions or solar
systems that
are um are at higher energies than the
hedgeon collider
and so the universe is a better hadron
collider than our large hadron collider
that's right it just requires you know
it's harder
you can't manipulate it right you just
have to wait what you want you got to
wait
until the particles find you right
exactly the part will bite you in the
ass
okay i guess you exist it's it's
basically like being
a an actor don't call us we'll call you
exactly just gotta wait for it to roll
up
all right so all right so so that's good
i i like that
and so but i want to emphasize a point
you made before we go to the next
question what you're saying is
in our life experience if something
lasts three minutes or five seconds or
one second
that's not very much time and who cares
about the difference
but in the early universe they're things
that lasted a trillionth of a second
and then a a quadrillionth of a second
and we say oh that's just
less than a second but each of those are
huge differences
in the energetics of the early universe
is that a fair way to think about it
absolutely i mean there's stuff that can
be created
in the first you know trillions of
trillions of trillions of seconds
that very quickly decay away into other
stuff and will never be made again
because the energy scale required to
create a single particle
with that mass even though the mass
itself is objectively not a lot compared
to
you know a coffee cup it's a lot for one
particle
um and it will never be made again
probably in the history of the universe
wow so anything that was born in the
first trillionth of a trillionth of a
second
and dies
a trillionth of a second later lived for
a trillion of its own lifetimes
yeah okay i mean that was a full life
right man that's that was it's life
expectancy
wow look at that yeah okay so we do
think like you can make in fact it's
possible that one of the
heaviest single particles that
ever could be made is a microscopic
black hole
and that it was made not by dead stars
not by collapsing matter but it was made
as like a
quantum particle in the very early
universe and that it was
the weight of like a little pile of
flour
but it was incredibly smaller than a
nucleus
right so it's very dense to be a black
hole it's black hole down exactly it's
very spatially tiny but heavy for its
incredibly small spatial size and if i
lost my keys into a microscopic black
hole
yeah don't don't reach in to pull them
out because that ain't gonna work
i'll get you another pair of keys
another set of keys for what you're
doing it's like chapter three and black
hole survival
so you know this reminds me of janna i i
forgot which book forgive me
but the the novelist kurt vonnegut yeah
one of his novels
uh he says this is the last
sentence ever spoken by humankind
it was one scientist speaking to the
other and says let's try it the other
way
that's the end of all civilization
so it's like let's see if we can make a
mini black hole last word ever spoken
well so there was some discussion
serious discussion about whether or not
the large hadron collider could make one
of these
and a mini black hole a mini black hole
and we usually think no you really
couldn't until you were at the much much
much higher energy but
it does turn out that the universe does
have extra spatial dimensions
and they're of a certain size you could
actually manipulate the strength of
gravity if you think about it gravity
dilutes when you have more dimensions
like more volume it gets more dilute so
if these dimensions you start to notice
it brings the scale of making black
holes down in energy
because gravity is getting uh it's it's
it's getting
into your range because of these extra
dimensions so what you're saying is
if you have extra dimensions then the
gravity has more
space to dilute into yeah right but that
means that
your thresholds of gravity bad stuff is
lower
is lower so you might make a black hole
at the large hadron collider
if that's the case and so there were
injunctions taken out by people to try
to stop the large hadron collider from
turning on
because there was this anxiety well if
you're going to make a black hole it's
going to like
digest you know it's going to consume
the earth it'll kill us all
um but the argument which might not be
very soothing because it is theoretical
is that they would evaporate too quickly
they would just go off like firecrackers
so you're saying
you would possibly make them and they
would consume the earth except that
hawking radiation protects us that's
right and we look black holes are not as
dangerous as people portray there's a
black hole in the center of our galaxy
we orbit that black hole
it dominates the entire behavior of the
galaxy and
uh it doesn't it's not a vacuum cleaner
says the person who wrote the book black
hole survival guy
right no one's no one writes a book
um if you want to survive just stay here
basically
no one writes the book the puppy
survival guide no you want survival
guides
with stuff that's going to eat you okay
that's funny this is the kitten survival
guy no no black hole
survival guy explorer's peril we got to
take a quick break when we come back
more cosmic queries when star talk
returns
we're back star talk cosmic queries we
are celebrating the release
of the second star talk book cosmic
queries
inspired by this format and we've got
with me by the way we're gonna have
different guests for the different kinds
of chapters that are in the book
and right now we've got some very deep
questions about what's the universe made
of and
how did the universe get to be this way
jan 11
always good to have you you're a good
friend of the show and thank you and by
the way
that place behind you this looks like a
bunker
but it's but it looks like a like a
chill place to never be found
so where are you right now so i am
uh also director of sciences at a
cultural center in brooklyn called
pioneer works which is
largely originated in the arts and um
and i've been doing science events here
and
bringing science into the community it's
very much that is just so brooklyn cool
i had to say this is the what i love
about this place it's free
and it's open to all and it's a donation
only model and we
we really bring like amazing people here
to talk about science to talk about art
to
have exhibitions and it's really
important to us that the doors are open
for everybody
and the intersection between science and
art is much greater than anyone ever
thinks about or imagines and you're
there
in the middle of that so keep keep up
the good work all right so chuck give me
some questions for our cosmologist in
the house
toby sonnenberg says hey dr tyson and dr
levin sometimes physicists say that the
existence
of a particle such as the axion
is predicted by a theory or completes
a theory what do they mean by this
oh good question well
that's okay so let's you know what the
best example of that is
is the higgs which we already mentioned
so
we looked at the standard model of all
the matter in the universe and there was
just like
one thing missing because
there was there we couldn't make sense
of
why particles had masses essentially
unless
the higgs was proposed so that what the
higgs does
it's basically higgs was a person peter
hicks
what was the person it's a person okay
posed the theory
and the idea of the higgs particle was
that that
there was this field that permeated all
of space kind of like what we think
about dark energy
so some people wondered if dark energy
itself was like
the higgs permeating all of space but
the numbers didn't quite work out
but it could be something like that dark
energy could be something like this
field that permeates all space
and as we move through this field
because of our interactions with the
higgs
it creates a kind of inertia we get
sticky we get gluey
it's like viscous moving through it and
that's what gives us mass
right mass is means i'm harder to push
around
than a thimble but i'm less hard to push
around
than a car there's inertia and this
difficulty pushing around has to do with
our interaction through the field
what's the idea so so the higgs particle
was filling a gap so that's different
from discovering a particle that nobody
ordered
that's true so like robbie said it's a
great quote
the physicist robbie said who ordered
that when he began to discover
more particles so the higgs was
predicted to fill a gap
which is exactly what the question was
about and lo and behold there it was
this can make all you all very proud of
yourselves right because it means
you you you understand not only the
physics that we've discovered
but the physics are waiting to be
discovered that that's that gives you
pretty good confidence there that's the
best
although i have to say everyone really
hoped
that something like the large hadron
collider would just would discover
something we had never predicted
but people don't understand about
physicists we don't want to wrap it all
up in a bow and be done we want more
and so it would have been incredibly
exciting if they had discovered
something
that nobody had ordered so you you look
forward to being work
deep in ignorance yes we look forward to
the questions the questions are the fun
part in fact robbie who you're quoting
his mother used to say to him did you
ask a good question today
yes i like that so basically you guys
are doing something basically you guys
are just never satisfied it's what you
really see
that's right yeah it's a weird job like
the more questions you answer you're
getting yourself out of work
[Laughter]
okay you want job security all right
here it goes
all right all right let's keep it going
and let's do a lead in
up to a lightning round so let's do a
little faster and then we'll pick up the
pace and see how how far we can get
well that's a perfect segue into john
schwelbach's question
because john says this hi janna uh
please tell me what is string theory in
two sentences
well he wants it in two sentences there
you go
okay he's right on time okay
go for it string theory is actually so
compelling because it can be summarized
in two sentences
when we look at the microscopic universe
we used to think we saw little
fundamental particles
it's possible that if we zoom in on
those fundamental particles all of which
are different there's a lot of them
quarks and electrons that when we zoom
in we realize that they're each
tiny loops of string the same kind of
string and they're playing different
harmonics on the string
to express as a different particle
so an electron is simply ringing at a
different note
than a quark but they are fundamentally
the same that was more than two
sentences
but it was good that was good that was
good so you're saying everything in the
universe could be made up of strings
that's right even light photons even the
higgs how about dark matter
all of it would be the same fundamental
string playing different notes
wow wow so the string will be playing
notes that we can't detect right such as
dark matter dark energy
that we can't see i say right so we
think of particles as just
their identity in terms of whether they
interact in certain ways and so all of
those features it's like a short list of
numbers
are harmonics on this chain so the
universe is nothing more than one
big version of name that tune
and this is the one we're in we're stuck
in this one in this movement
all right give me another one good short
answer janet that's so funny best short
answer ever
if somebody else is able to observe us
but we can't observe them could you
imagine they'd be like god what a shitty
song
all right so this is woody what he says
is a quantum vacuum possible
in intergalactic space or anywhere else
and would an area of absolute nothing
be a hole in space time
so if you can actually get to nothing
did you
punch a hole in space-time well there's
a lot of stuff going on there
yes there is quantum aspect is the most
important to some extent
you can never have a quantum completely
nothing a vacuum nothing you can't have
a complete quantum vacuum
and that's because of the heisenberg
uncertainty principle says you know i
can't ever
really precisely state that a particle's
there or not there
it means i can't say it nothing exists
because i have the same uncertainty okay
there's an uncertainty there's no
listening even existence let me know
yeah wait you can't be easy on chuck
jenner easy on chuck chuck had a hard
night last night exactly
you're laying this on him now i drank
last night you said let me know
damn no oh yeah
so you know to say there's nothing means
you have zero uncertainty that there's
nothing
right and you cannot have that at the
quantum level it doesn't exist there is
no
it's not just that there's a problem
with the human knowledge there is no
meaning to saying it's exactly precisely
empty
so you're saying that something can't
exist is basically what you're saying
they're can't
be there can't be a nothing they're just
because
no no no no no it's not that there can't
be nothing you cannot be
sure that there's nothing well there's
nothing
isn't quite as empty as you might
imagine
the most nothing you can get
might be so this is why people talk
about the dark energy as being the
energy of the vacuum
the most nothing you might be able to
get is this kind of frothy
quantum things a cloud of possibilities
and that has an energy associated with
it and you can calculate the energy
associated with it and
and so far we keep getting the number
wrong if i look at quantum mechanics as
i understand it and i calculate the
energy of the vacuum
i either get zero or i get something
absolutely enormous
what i don't get is dark energy so you
could say dark energy is not mysterious
what's mysterious
is why it's so low why it's either
not zero or huge and that's what the
real mystery is is how do we
how do we make the energy of the vacuum
tuned
just to where what we observe and
and uh nobody knows how to do that all
right i i crow i cry foul here
wait so so what you you are taking as a
given
that everything you're describing is
happening in
the space time that we've come to know
and love but back to the person's
question
if you did find a place where the
quantum laws don't
apply have you torn uh
have you opened up a rip in the very
fabric of space time
where possibly other rules of quantum
behavior apply
well or no rules at all yeah i would say
that that
uh to do such violence as to have
a hole in space-time so you have to
think of space-time as being
formed responding flexibly to matter and
energy and
so you can't make a hole without having
tremendous
other phenomenon going on it just it we
know what the solution would be would be
nice smooth empty space time
so you make a hole by doing something
like a black hole like doing some
some real intense violence with energy
and matter
to create that whole so i would say i
would say maybe closer
answer to uh our listeners question is
that it might be quite the other way
around that quantum mechanics
creates space-time and that is a new
idea that's been
kind of people been flirting with maybe
for decades but that
it's not that you have these two
separate things gravity space-time
quantum it's that things like a black
hole
emerge from the quantum phenomena
and not the other way around so you
don't even have space time
right unless you have quantum mechanics
i get it so you can't
even pose the question what happens if
there's no
exactly you can't separate the existence
of space time from the quantum phenomena
that operates within it if it's in fact
they created it in the first place
yeah if that's so one way to think of it
is like embroidery so embroidery
like let's say you're you're you're
embroidering something each
thread is like a quantum phenomena and
from far away
it might look like a black hole but on
closer inspection you realize it's a
bunch of inter-tangled quantum threads
right exactly wow that's cool that's a
really cool concept
it's pretty cool i'm just saying i can't
i can't wait to go to a party with a
bunch of theoretical physics and do
whatever drugs they are doing
[Laughter]
we'll sign you up truck exactly fast
lightning round let's do it okay here we
go my name is pronounced
frederick uh if the universe is
with everything expands does that mean
that quarks grow
too or is it just the space between them
okay
very good question question lightning
round go yeah here i am in brooklyn
brooklyn is not expanding
famous reference to annie hall so
locally i'm bound to the earth i'm not
expanding with the expansion of the
universe because
locally the earth is more important to
me also my atoms are bound together by
different forces and
they're stronger than the expansion rate
of the universe presently i'm not being
torn apart
if that's maintained in the future uh
remains
to be understood it might be that the
expansion gets faster and faster and
eventually indeed
brooklyn begins to expand and um
and that's just something we don't know
about the fate of the universe and in
fact
the final chapter of the cosmic queries
book
takes you there it looks at
the great rip the runaway where not only
does everything get ripped apart from
everything else
the very structure of
particle matter itself breaks apart it
can't even hold itself together
that scared me i lost sleep that night
it doesn't scare me i've been in that
position many times
well i just can't hold myself together
you can't hold yourself because you
can't hold myself together
all right chuck we're actually out of
time but i want to get one more question
in here
hey jana hey neil i love you both big
fan for a long time and thank you both
for instilling me with a cosmic
perspective
in our universe we observe virtual
particles that pop in and out of
existence
could this phenomenon be compared to
that of a 3d object passing through
a 2d flatland i love that
it's very interesting well it is
possible so i said string theory
but i only had two sentences which i
already overused but
it is possible that there aren't just
strings but there are membranes higher
dimensional surfaces
and so imagine yes we started with
particles points and then we went to
strings one-dimensional objects now
maybe
there's like a membrane a
two-dimensional object and maybe there's
higher dimensional objects as high as
you can fit
and the higher dimensional space-time so
one of the ideas is imagine we
live on like a three-dimensional
membrane and when we see a point
particle
it's really the end point of a string
stuck to our membrane
wow it's not exactly the question asked
no no but it is it is the intersection
of dimension that's so
cool though yeah yeah so that i see a
point particle moving around in my space
time because i can't
see that it's really connected by a
string to somewhere else
and also imagine how that allows for
what would appear
as an illusion to be faster than light
travel right because
i could have this thing that's actually
connected and it's doing something
you know synced up but that's because
it's fundamentally connected and
that's amazing so it's like to having
the point of a pencil
down on the paper and the point is what
i'm seeing on the paper exactly but then
there's a whole
a whole pencil connected to that point
yeah okay that's some freaky freaky
stuff man that's freaky friday
so when we calculate the energy of the
vacuum and try to find the dark energy
we have to calculate
all of these kinds of objects that might
be in the universe and what they're
contributing in their quantum
energy to the vacuum wow damn
we got to close it there
i'm not gonna sleep for three days right
now
janet thanks for showing us your your
digs at pioneer works
and and chuck chuck you you tweet at
chuck nice comic
yes always good to find you there thank
you sir for saying it i just love that
janna has pioneer works it's like right
and jenna we see your pioneer works your
uh your your your swan song
accomplishment to science
and truck tweets to tweet right
[Laughter]
all right so we just encourage you to
check out cosmic
as the second star talk book national
geographic
press i'm neil degrasse tyson you're a
personal astrophysicist
and of course i bid you to keep
you